ah there's nothing in the human world
that feels like this oh they are squishy
what am i doing smashing
squish squish squish squish [ __ ] I have
never heard of squishes before maybe
they're a new type of fidgets better
Squishy's are these little foamy
creatures I've seen other people with
them and I get super jealous and I
really want one they look so fun and
cool and cute
I think squishies are trending because
the world we live in just keeps on
getting more and more stressful
I see where they get the name from now
oh this is this is fun this feels like a
stress ball but it's like even squishier
and they're super soft these are like
dog toys for adults
I don't actively play with any toys so
as an adult can I have all of them I
really like these way more than I
thought I would do they smell good I
feel like if I choose one than the other
squishies are gonna be sad that it
didn't use them they're all staring at
me look do you see this right now I'm
gonna take this with me for a week just
hang out with it play around with it and
kind of see how it affects me I'm pretty
sure I will get into fights with kids
who will try to grab this from me and
that's not happening these are my toys
I'm a very stressed person so I feel
like they'll be in handy when I'm
stressed as am I supposed to like
squeeze it when I'm like upset I think
I'm already addicted I might talk to
them it's been less than an hour and I'm
already just starting to destroy it but
it's stress relief a man walking down
the road like squishing a lemon it's
kind of a weird look however I'm
enjoying it I've had them for a couple
days now and they still smell freaking
delicious oh my god this is like vanilla
wafers it smells good so I like how long
it takes so they go back to the resin
for
he's not to be happy in a second I feel
kind of wrong for like squishing this
cute creature oh let me smash it it's
really kind of grown on me and I still
find myself like subconsciously just
like squeezing it throughout the day or
like fiddling around with it I like put
it on my desk I just like man [ __ ] I'm
the type of person that fidgets a lot
I'm like constantly like biting on my
sweater and tapping my foot a little
dubaku bear has helped me a lot with
like my vision a
we're about to take off usually this is
what I squeeze my husband's hand
as I do for a count but Jason's gonna
have to do this time
[Music]
respect it have a co-worker just trying
to steal him from me
not good that's so relaxed right now no
I need it back I liked it when I saw
everyone in the office had them I wanted
one really bad so I I stole one
I forgot my Daisy in my finit eco right
here in this studio I didn't think it
was going to affect me so much oh my god
I miss it so freaking much I really
really really did I'm at the airport I
had a minor freak out because I thought
I left it at home
and I went to like grab it and my heart
stopped because I didn't think I had it
my backpack I have become squishy
reliant I have an addiction they're not
really a stress reliever for me they're
more of my friends and they keep me
company I think some people are scared
of me now I've definitely noticed that
I've grown closer to it I have to throw
it away because I have destroyed what I
once loved so literally squished it all
weekend while I was laying in bed sick I
really loved it and like I'm still
holding on to it he's really brought out
side of me that I did not expect to have
I was kind of surprised that I was so
like emotionally and physically attached
to it they are my best friends now I
feel like it was a place to like channel
anxiety subconsciously it's been a
really great stress reliever for me I
have it today not a fan of flying
if anything happens at least I'm gonna
die squeezing my squeeze it felt really
like therapeutic actually I think it's
just having something to like do with my
hands while I'm focused on another
activity it looks like my dog chewed it
but it was just me maybe I'm more
stressed out than I think that I am I
feel like maybe what I learned is that
toys aren't just for kids you know and
play with toys and you can take your
mind off things
I also learned that I love to squish
things it was a major surprise to
realize that yes you're becoming part of
me it's almost like an extension
definitely staying on my desk you can
pry my Squishy out of my cold dead hands
yes there's no way you were taking these
from me anyway so I wish everybody could
feel how squishy this is just like
imagine
you